ludwig wird es herausfinden vielleicht
später in der sendung us-präsident seine
cnn journalistin angebracht hat joachim
news ist klar die trump jahre werden für
die medien kein zuckerschlecken
was tun sich mit witz und wahrheit
wappnen sowie das treffen der berühmte
us amerikaner mit schweizer wurzeln hat
eine antwort vom pflügen humor und
journalistische präsidium von hier aus
kämpft grevener gegen donezk war heißt
es wieder donald trump tötet vor der
presse in einem die donald trump wurde
das ist die wahrheit dann wichtig durch
werk drückt einem deutschen präsidenten
musste nicht aufbauschen seine witze
zielen auf das viele fassungslos macht
ein präsident der lebt und die presse
verunglückt ist furchtbar kann ich ihn
mit einer frage gestellt gerade eine
frage sein funktion als highlight
beantworten keine fragen
vor anderthalb jahren übernimmt genauer
die daily show hat der felge satiriker
zu den einflussreichsten stimmen im us
amerikanischen fernsehen
geboren wird er während der apartheid in
südafrikanischen verwertung als kind
einer schwarzen einheimischen und eines
weißen schweizers
aus dem township schafft er es bis in
die königsklasse der unterhaltungsshows
von nordamerika
[Applaus]
seine comedy muss keine nachrichten mehr
erfinden denn nun schafft er genügend
fake news ein präsident der wie seine
eigene parodie wirklich ein vorzeitiges
ende des tranken theater wünscht sich
trainer noch nicht ich möchte dass
amerika die gelegenheit bekommt sich
selbst irgendwie zu entscheiden feindes
auf wenn es ein amtsenthebungsverfahren
gegen trump gibt wenn die wähler nicht
mehr selber sagen das ist nicht unser
mann werden ort auge setzen sie will
traurige realsatire kritische geister
letzter präsident auf der
pressekonferenz werfen unliebsame medien
schaffen wir sind für ihn der volksfeind
nummer eins darauf hat er die einzig
richtige antwort
immer mehr leute schon jetzt kommt es
gut weil gute satire die wahrheit zeigt
nachrichtensendung in amerika
informieren nicht mehr recht was sie
wollen vor allem unterhalten lassen
leute aufeinander los aber das ist kein
journalist mission verlogene politik zu
entlarven
mit humor
[Musik]
[Applaus]